بعض كلمات التحذير والنصائح من
الممثل هيو جاكمان هذا الأسبوع، لقد أجريت للتو
خزعتين، وذهبت للتو إلى
طبيبتي ورأت أن الأشياء الصغيرة
يمكن أن تكون أو لا تكون القاعدة أو
الخلية، وثق بي، ثق بي، ثق بي هذا
هذه كل الأشياء التي حدثت منذ 25 عامًا،
وهي تظهر الآن، وقد
عولج جاكمان عدة مرات من قبل من
سرطان الجلد ولحسن الحظ جاءت نتائجه
سلبية هذه المرة ولكن
يظل التحذير وفقًا لمؤسسة سرطان الجلد،
واحد من كل خمسة أمريكيين سيصاب
بسرطان الجلد  بحلول الوقت الذي
يبلغون فيه 70 عامًا، السببان الأكثر شيوعًا هما
التعرض لأشعة الشمس فوق البنفسجية
وأسرة التسمير، ولكن كيف تؤثر الشمس على
بشرتنا، يشرح الدكتور سانجاي جوبتا
الخلايا الحرشفية والخلايا القاعدية الموجودة
هناك في تلك البشرة، هذا ما
يمكن أن يكون  تتأثر بالشمس ويمكن أن
تتحور ويمكن أن تتحول إلى سرطان
لديك أيضًا نوع آخر من الخلايا تعرف
باسم الخلايا الصباغية إذا أصبحت متحورة
يمكن أن تتحول إلى سرطان الجلد إلى جانب
وضع واقي الشمس مع عامل حماية من الشمس مرتفع
تأكد من إجراء فحوصات روتينية لجسمك
تذكر الحماية  التعرض للشمس لا
يعني انعدام المتعة، خذها من ولفيرين، ضع
بعض الواقي من الشمس، ستظل تقضي
وقتًا رائعًا هناك، حسنًا،
من فضلك كن آمنًا، أنا أبلغ إيفان رودريجيز